when I was leaving Ramon someone on that  Friday morning I'm taking my seven half  of the company out with me he said  you'll never succeed without me and I  think he gave me the Freitas let me tell  you thank God he said that to me because  when I heard those words I thought to  myself watch me I'd rather die and let  me tell you something that was my  insurance policy for success and I know  that's an attitude shift and maybe not  even from a good place I probably need a  good shift to get over could shrink to  get over myself but that shift in my gut  gave me power and so wherever you get  your power you know it's amazing I meet  so many of my entrepreneurs I'm always  looking for the magic sauce before I put  my money in them and very often the  recurring magic sauce is they have  something to prove and many proving an  insult is not true  so I love an entrepreneur that has  something to prove